[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
in sallys und ellas welt heute möchten
wir euch zeigen wie ihr last minute
geschenke machen könnt ich habe auch
schon in den letzten jahren viele last
minute ideen gemacht geschenke aus der
küche weil ich finde dass an weihnachten
gerade wenn man in sola konsum belebt
wie heute ist doch immer wieder umso
wichtiger dinge selbst zu machen
menschen zeit zu schenken und vor allem
finde ich kommt es nicht auf die größe
der geschenke an sondern wirklich auf
die wertschätzung und ich finde wenn man
das selber macht dann weiß die person da
hat jemand zeit investierte hat jemand
lieber reingesteckt vieles machen wir
jetzt und das sind so geschenke die kann
man an freunde kollegen bekannte
verwandte nachbarn verschenken und heute
machen wir davon 3 was leckeres zum
essen kam
später
katholiken
aber was steht da kann ich nicht
genau jetzt nicht mehr zuerst einmal
heiße schokolade zum verschenken machen
und zwar im schönen glas renault das
warten war gleich auch schön und ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten also auch für
die heiße schokolade klar könnt ihr
einfach cover verwenden trinkschokolade
könnt ist aber auch ganz einfach zeit
hat und selber mischen und zwar
verwendet jeder für kakaopulver und hier
achtet ihr einfach nur drauf dass es
nicht so ein stark erhöhtes cacau kultur
ist also ganz noch einfach kakao aus dem
so mancher stellt er nicht gelöst denn
wenn ihr zu stark in telfs verkaufen
verwendet dann vermischt sich das nicht
so gut mit der milch
was steht da
ja genauso buch gelesen hat
sich anfangen
und was steht da drauf
[Musik]
wir zeigen jetzt erstmal die zutaten für
das kakao das mischgetränk denn wir
vermischen verkauft man nehme nur 30
gramm und neben 50 gramm puderzucker und
damit aber sondern sally touch bekommt
und einfach eine eigene note wird
schreibe ich hier noch etwas top up ohne
mit rein und damit das ganze dekorativ
wäre und geschmacklich auch noch einmal
aufgewertet werden kann könnt ihr hier
noch verschiedene tolle dekorative am
lebensmittel verwenden wie zum beispiel
hier die metallic shopper flex dann die
talks with the troggs chris pearls in
zwei varianten einmal zweiter und hält
dann nehme ich ganz gerne hier noch
diese gold sterne sie sind auch richtig
schön und zum verpacken haben wir dann
die reagenzgläser genau die
reagenzgläser verpacker was rein und
dann kann man das einfach schön
verschenken jetzt die heiße schokolade
mission also das ist trinkt
schokoladenpulver haudrauf man
reinmachen
sehr groß und puder zu können
auch sehr gut die tonkabohne
also eher können hier rede kam er auf
einen extrakt oder tonka
patienten jetzt lieber die trockene
tonga schon kannte ich schon mit stoffen
mischung hätte genau richtig schreiben
hatte ich mal kurz den anfangs für dich
nämlich mich das so seit drückst du
darfst du noch ein bisschen aber
langsame so
schneller vorankommen
[Musik]
jetzt nicht
richtig hammerbacher schon seit april
war selber gewischt
da kann es auch ihre stimme abzugeben
lebkuchengewürz was ihr ebenso gerne mit
der nasen kann übrigens sein dass
staaten gast dazu kommt in rio noch mal
gespannt
hast du richtig gedroppt
und dann könnt ihr euch hier aus papier
einfach so einen trichter basteln
aber wir hatten nicht so einen kleinen
trichter
man muss man kreativ sein aber durchaus
schupp sagt du willst mal machen
genau jetzt nehmen wir hier einfach die
zutaten die schönen dekorativ sind aber
eben auch geschmack bringen
gleich noch besser drop sie sind auch
schön
mini marshmallows sind übrigens auch
schon können sie auch mit rein geben und
dann kann man diese bläschen an
verpacken ich werde jetzt hier gleich
noch so zu einer stange drum machen dass
wir es packen im nacken wir machen
geschenke aber wir machen das
hast du dich gerade gelöst das ist doch
ein schönes geschenk
ach so ich habe mir gedacht wir machen
so nach ihnen waren zettel dran das ist
halt für heiße schokolade und dann kann
man sich das nehmen und mild war machen
oder pflanzliche mit kann das reinhören
und dann am weihnachtsabend oder einfach
so im winter wenn es ist einfach
genießen
also befinden sie jetzt mal weiter
einen zähler getrennt
[Musik]
findest du backen cola oder kochen
backen machen nämlich
nicht
einfach
und ist nicht geschützt
werden teller hier jetzt noch weiter
werkelt kann ich schon mal das nächste
geschenk vorbereitet und dafür brauche
ich jetzt ein bisschen kuvertüre denn
jetzt machen wir tannenbaum lollis
schokoladen tannenbäume am stiel machen
wir machen
und da noch tannenbaum noll ist und
dafür werde ich zur türe schmelzen und
nehme jetzt einfach mal 100 gramm tabak
ouvertüre und schmelz ticos in der
mikrowelle oder ihr könnt auch
zwangsrabatt nehmen also ich möchte
jetzt hier axica peter kuvertüre in der
mikrowelle 26 800 watt für eine minute
dann umrühren immer wieder rausholen für
10 20 sekunden nach stellen bis
geschmolzen ist
jetzt die charaktere geschmolzen und
dann gebt ihr nochmal 50 gramm kaffee
tee schokolade
doch normal und damit könnte ich jetzt
die kuvertüre wird darunter also ich
tempo rasiert sich kristallisieren damit
die lollipops gleich die wir auch
spritzen werden auch schon in form
bleiben und auch bei raumtemperatur fest
dass nämlich immer ganz wichtig dass
kuvertüre gut und richtig verarbeitet
wenn dann machen wir immer zwei mal pro
tag zwei monaten heute nicht fertig
werden aber eigentlich müsste ich schon
fertig
tannenbäume aus schokolade
ohne cache ja
[Musik]
ja sehr schön damit testen jetzt gleich
kuvertüre und zwar werde ich damit jetzt
einfach so eine spitze rein taufe und
hier ablegen und wenn es dann innerhalb
von einer minute schön fest wird und
schon glänzt dann habt ihr die perfekte
kubatur anpassbar ist
der name hier
[Musik]
die kuvertüre ist jetzt perfekt man
sieht's auch hier ganz groß schaut mal
an dieser schokoladen probe man sieht
hier dass die kultur fest wird oder auch
eben und schönen glanz bekommt und das
wirklich innerhalb von sekunden
innerhalb von einer minute ungefähr
und gefällt und jetzt gibt es einen
trick wenn ihr nämlich jetzt die
schokolade nimmt in einen spritzbeutel
fühlt und aufschrift dann passiert das
ganze vielleicht ist euch auch schon mal
aufgefallen die läuft ein bisschen
auseinander und damit die jetzt ein
bisschen zähflüssiger wird also auch
wenn jetzt mal eine schrift schreiben
wollt oder was ornamente spritzen wollt
dann macht ihr das ist so nehmt euch
einfach ein bisschen kuvertüre
und jetzt dürft ihr etwas wovon hier
eigentlich immer dachte man gab es gar
nicht
ihr dürft jetzt endlich ein bisschen
wasser dazugeben aber wirklich immer nur
ganz ganz wenig immer noch ganz wenige
tropfen
wer will kann
und dadurch rennt die schokolade sich
mehr die bleibt dann einfach schön in
form und dann kann man wunderbar
schriften machen und wirklich toll
schreiben
macht aber wirklich tröpfchen für
tröpfchen
ich habe jetzt auch noch mal schokolade
wird so wir gehen weil ich hätte kurz
ein bisschen zu kurz ein paar tropfen
waren
und jetzt gleicht immer aus hass so ganz
gut jetzt nämlich den kleinen
spritzbeutel könnte auch aus bangkok ihr
euch ein kleines
rädchen drehen muss sagen war man sieht
auf die gleise verzug
erstellt ich muss sagen ich mag es mit
den mini spritzbeutel lieber weil ich da
einfach nicht aufpassen muss dass das
hinten rauskommt die ist einfach schön
fest instabil und diese ampel
falttechnik mit dem backpapier die muss
man ein bisschen üben
muss weg ist ein ganz einfacher trick
mit dem wasser mit diesem
wassertröpfchen aber es funktioniert zu
fahren dann vorne eine ganz kleine
spitze wegschneiden um dann könnt ihr im
prinzip einfach euren tannenburg
spritzen
jetzt sieht man auch ganz gut dass der
wirklich schön die form behält
können wir jetzt auch vorher aufmalen
wenn ihr wollt
dann den stil rein und dein nachbar und
dann entsteht so ein bisschen vor und
zurückbewegen dass er auch wirklich fest
ist ohne schicht drüber
ich will liebe so zieht sich gemacht
dass sie gerne
dann kommt das allerwichtigste
nämlich
dekorieren die krise
gekommen ist hier so kleine tricks drauf
und top box und sternchen
besonders schöne deko team torten
reinstecken könnten wir ganz einfach
torte buttercreme in krems dann könnt
ihr diese tannenbäumchen
oder auch mal ein café klein oder eben
ganz einfach
ich mache ja auch so natürlich
lasse ich es dir aufzeichnen vorher
kommt man am besten hältst du das so
dann solltest du das runter damit so ein
bisschen spannung ist und ich zeige dir
am besten ein baum vor so können das mit
kindern machen
trage ich über die kann sein die sonne
wie die spitze schnell fest
so
so so jetzt kannst du es aufhört
[Musik]
bei uns gibt's die beiden stücke dort
gibt es im moment noch vor weihnachten
bei mir zu hause eingeben aber dann
waren da drin sind willkommen
kanada war im laden nur mit spielsachen
nicht rein weil ich erst wieder raus
ich sehe ihn bei
ganze anhänger machten ich glaub ich hab
ihn bewerbung hast du das gesehen
sie ist
keine schokolade ist schon fest wo man
das gut finde es auch schön also wenn
man nicht so schnell arbeitet und werden
tatsächlich die ersten bäume schon
chance innerhalb von wenigen minuten und
dann könnte die schön verpacken und
verschenken ja das ist so praktisch die
zweite idee und jetzt machen wir noch
buch schokolade haben uns gedacht hoch
schokolade es nämlich so ein phänomen da
kann man auch eine schöne große menge
machen kann sich da kreativ austoben und
es auch hübsch verpacken und verschenken
oder man versteht einfach direkt gleich
sowie die älteste macht
was willst du besser verschenken oder
direkt vernaschen
oder beides
also dann nehme ich jetzt noch mal komme
türe diesmal nämlich jetzt eine karamell
kuvertüre die schnecke richtig schön
parallel ich hatte auch eine schöne
farbe und die
genauso wie gerade eben
also emma ist jetzt raus mit lara sehr
chaotisch jetzt kommt nicolet nicolet
erwarte ich schon seit tagen
ich freue mich auf den tag wenn heute
ist sie da ein video habt ihr schon
gesehen aber
chronologisch gesehen ist sie jetzt
gerade hier eingetroffen und das video
was ihr schon gesehen hat weiß schon
ausgestellt wurde drehen wir morgen ist
herzlich willkommen
ich habe gerade einen scheck dass wir
schon auf sendung ach du die ganze zeit
schon alles gut ich bescheiden nur rein
was du willst ich bin total happy hier
zu sein das ist ganz ganz strange hier
in der küche zu stehen das ist einfach
noch gigantischer als man das wohnzimmer
sieht
wahnsinn ja und wir haben uns halt
gedacht so lange wir warten wussten
nicht genau waren do kommt sie wussten
wieder verkehr wird überprüfe ich die
zeit mit ella und dreh mit ihr was und
jetzt ob die ich hab's dir beschäftigt
ich habe erst einstellen wenn ja wann
das so schöne sachen mitgebracht hast
und jetzt habe ich ein einlass ist
eigentlich kein rezept ist es weißt du
ich wollte ein video machen so drei
ideen zu weihnachten was man schön
machen kann hübsch verpacken und
verschenken so als kleinigkeit deswegen
gibt es einmal so hot chocolate strings
die man dann schoss verschenken kann wo
man dann so heiße milch auf mach es doch
gibt es auch in kugelform geht das ja
genau die hilfe mein mann öffentlich und
wird er noch schön verpackt
die tannenbäumchen und jetzt noch zum
buch schokolade also ich freue mich sehr
hier zu sein ist unglaublich
so hat ihr gleich so zusammen dekorieren
gerne
ich freue mich weil ich nicht so gut
machen kann und dekorieren ist so weist
auch nicht so mein ding
ich kann auch nicht so zu hause das
dekorieren
ich stelle auch immer irgendwas hat
einmal die zu dir kommen und dann ja
bei mir schlafen gibt immer viel
ich habe da eine schöne auszeit so konso
rose bei mir hier ja ja ja ohne man ohne
kinder oder nachhallt gehst du nach
hause sagt ich hab ich hatte urlaub
muss man sagen genug ihr neues leben als
das dekorieren gehen also wäre ich habe
jetzt hier die toppings und jetzt habe
ich einfach schokolade geschmolzen und
gis die hier rein weil hoch schokolade
ist so einfach man kann wirklich einfach
schokolade schönen temporäre schmelzen
hier in der form gießen mit back folie
oder backpapier und dann der chor das
schön und könnte später auseinander
brechen das ist karamell liebe karamell
ja das ist mein lieblingsding jahre
karamell und richtig dunkle schokolade
herren schokolade die dunklen desto
besser ist also richtig hart dass es
manchen schon die schuhe auszieht voll
mein sehr gut dann verstehen wir uns
dennoch ein festgesetzter teil
was ist das für eine auflockerung von
tieren ja jetzt alles von
lang einfach zu wir haben jetzt angst
dass hier das ist doch die gerne das
schön dass wir hier in storkow flakes
die sind auch sehr lecker nicht so viel
von seinem thron foto maxim vorstände
gemacht nur die hälfte mit drogen über
frische fürchten ja das macht es aus
dass tee und essen blüten blüten
mischung
passt es riecht ein bisschen die
meerschweinchen futter
aufgefallen oder wieso sägespäne wie
streu tanz seine kaninchen unterbringt
im stall es riecht so ein bisschen
willkommen bei lekkerland ireland
schokolade so spannend wie könnt ihr
natürlich in allen variationen machen
top drauf was schmeckt was euch gefällt
die packen jetzt im kühlschrank da wird
sie fest und dann kann man so
auseinanderbrechen und verpacken macht
es die buch schokolade noch mal kurz
ohne ella und ohne die toilette wobei
ich sagen muss man sieht bei der bruch
schokolade
den einfluss von nicollette viel hilft
viel und es war natürlich jetzt ein
bisschen über dekoriert aber ich finde
es schön also die benutze ich auf jeden
fall auch die wird dann auch gebrochen
aber ich werde jetzt einfach noch mal
drei sorten machen und am besten macht
ihr es euch so dass ihr euch vorher
vielleicht so ein parkkonzept überlegt
das heißt in dem durch die toppings
hierhin wie zum beispiel für die
karamell schokolade da werde ich jetzt
die pistazien nehmen und die weißen job
box diese gold sterne die immer schön
weihnachtlich aussehen hier habe ich ein
bisschen haselnüsse und erdnuss
bekanntes ortet carroll erkannt und
diese chris powers und dann habe ich mir
hier noch am park gerichtet für
zartbitter schokolade und hier noch ein
paar für ruby oder für weiße schokolade
das weiß firmen aber was auf jeden fall
sehr wichtig ist dass eben die kuvertüre
temperiert ist die habe ich jetzt hier
einmal überprüft da warte ich jetzt noch
kurz und mir ist die in dem blech muss
ich sagen ein bisschen zu schnell fest
geworden also ein bisschen mehr
arbeitszeit hätte ich schon gerne
deswegen arbeite jetzt doch auf holz
weil meine arbeitsplatte einfach so
kalte schweiß eine steinplatte ist und
da ist eine bank folie drauf und dann
verstreiche ich das gleich mit der
palette
sobald ich sehe dass die kuvertüre fest
wird
[Musik]
also die sieht gut aus ich sehe die wird
schon fest und hat einen schönen glanz
das heißt auch nicht zu warm
und dann kann ich dir jetzt hier drauf
kippen und schön verteilen
und da meine toppings darauf geben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei der meisten schokolade nehme ich
jetzt kokos schütz ein paar
gefriergetrocknete erdbeeren trocknet
fliegt die in diesem ruby gold beige
drops silber sterne und ein paar chris
börsen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei der tat bitter schokolade verwende
ich als toppings die zar peter christoph
ein paar kakaobohnen also kaunitz
gehackte gerüstete haselnüsse jobs in
gold und gingerbread zucker dekor
[Musik]
wenn die schokolade kann fest ist könnt
ihr sie auseinanderbrechen am besten
nehmt ihr euch handschuhe damit ihr
keine fingerabdrücke hinterlässt und
dann brächte sie einfach aus landau in
grobe stücke
[Musik]
da könnt ihr jetzt die schokoladen
sorten einfach untereinander mischen
hübsch verpacken oder verschenken was
ich immer ganz gerne mache ich nehme zum
beispiel einen schönen teller oder nur
tortenplatte oder wenn ihr irgendwie ein
schönes geschirr teilhabe was ihr übrig
habt dann könnt ihr das da drauf packen
und einfach damit verschenken oder
einfach ein papier wickeln oder folie
[Musik]
also eigentlich wollte ich jetzt ein
video abschluss machen um euch die drei
geschenkideen zeigen aber ich muss euch
doch eine deko idee zeigen und zwar wie
hier muffins und habe daraus cupcakes
gemacht mit einer leckeren cremig habe
ziehe einfach so eine mascarpone
karamell creme drauf ein bisschen
glitzer schnee drüber ihr seht auch
schon wie schön der glitzert und wenn
ihr dann noch diese sieben fällen ist
waren sternchen nimmt diese gold stars
und wenn ihr dann diese glitzersteine
drauf habt könnt ihr hier das ganze rein
stecken und dann habt ihr wirklich auch
eine schöne cupcake dekoration
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier die drei
geschenkideen fertig also einmal die
schokoladen tannenbaum lollipops die ihr
entweder als lolli einzeln verpacken als
cupcake dekoration oder torten
dekoration nutzen könnt dann die bruch
schokolade in den verschiedenen
ausführungen und die könnte ja auch
schön in kleinen tütchen verpacken ob es
papiertüten oder folien das könnt ihr
dann selber entscheiden oder wie gesagt
auch trocken platte oder einem schönen
teller und dann noch hier diese
trinkschokolade hier könnt ihr
vielleicht auch noch wenn ihr möchtet
ein kleines kärtchen dazu schreiben dass
es eben eine trinkschokolade ist die man
eben mit pflanzlicher milch oder ganz
normaler am komisch eben benutzen kann
genau das sind die drei geschenkideen
schaut aber gerne auch noch mal auf
meinem kanal vorbei ich habe zum
beispiel auch schon pralinen zubereitet
das ist auch immer eine schöne
geschenkidee und vielleicht habt ihr
auch nur aus den letzten jahren schon
mal was zubereitet schreibt mir doch
gerne einfach mal auf euch so diese art
von videos gefallen weil ich finde so
kleinigkeiten sind schon immer ganz
hübsch zum verschenken ich wünsche euch
jetzt jedenfalls ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und viel erfolg beim
nachmachen zeigt mir gerne eure fotos
auf instagram und facebook und markiert
mich darauf an sehe ich nämlich auch was
ihr für schöne kleinigkeiten zu bereitet
habt also viel spaß und bis zum nächsten
mal
und die rezepte findet ihr auch alle auf
meinem blog bzw in meiner app
so haben wir auch ganz schön viel da und
das wird jetzt auch verschenkt
[Musik]